[Musique]
une question que beaucoup de personnes
se posent c'est est ce que l'on revient
en maître 2020 quand la pandémie
la première fois et la réponse est bien
évidemment non nous ne reviendrons pas à
l'époque des états unis font le plein
d'autotest ils viennent d'en acheter 500
millions et puis israël israël va lancer
la quatrième dose du vaccin pour les
plus de 60 ans et pour le personnel
médical la situation est critique elle
est critique parce que l'épidémie delta
circulent encore dans notre pays nous
atteignons des niveaux d'incidence
absolument inédit en france avec 73
mille cas positifs détectés hier ce qui
constitue une nouvelle fois un record
quelle est la part du variant omicron
aujourd'hui dans l'épidémie en france
aujourd'hui elle est environ à 20% sans
doute 30 ou 35 % en ile-de-france si
vous me posez la question dans deux
jours oui il faut répondre est que ce
sera déjà au moins une contamination sur
trois en france étaient majorité a en
tout cas entre noël et nouvel an ce que
l'on entend général dans les grands
médias c'est toujours une espèce de doxa
dominante qui consiste à terroriser les
fournées français n'auront terroristes
la vaccination les restrictions ne sont
pas exclues mais le coeur de notre
stratégie il est très simple ces
vaccinations vaccination vaccination
donc moi je demande aux entreprises de
se préparer dès maintenant pour
renforcer le télétravail à la rentrée
donc le 3 janvier avec une cible de
trois jours minimum pour les postes qui
le permettre voire quatre jours quand
c'est possible effectivement si on a
prévu de danser à 25 dans une pièce ça
c'est complètement débile quoi mais
c'est vraiment débile donc c'est la part
des choses que l'on peut se dire que
8,19 qui a fait deux victimes symbolique
en martinique lundi de représentants de
l'intersyndicale qui étaient très
mobilisées contre l'obligation vaccinale
alain de kayes 61 ans président de la
fédération des taxis indépendants
il était connu pour son engagement
contre la vaccination des soignants lui
même n'était pas vaccinée pourtant il
était diabétique sa femme envisage
aujourd'hui de se faire vacciner emea
gars 48 ans président du syndicat des
fonds dans les artistes de l'île
auraient été contaminés à l'occasion
d'une réunion de travail ou plusieurs
autres personnes ont contracté le virus
il faut plutôt se réjouir de ce virus
omicron puisqu'en fait c'est un virus
qui est extrêmement contagieux mais très
peu les tables et on ne parle que des
cas nouveau on ne parle pas des morts
d'évasion d'un détenu dans le val d'oise
incarcéré à la maison d'arrêt d'osny
l'homme de 28 ans en détention
provisoire pour assassinat avait été
emmené à l'hôpital de pontoise après une
automutilation sur le parking d'une
femme complice l'attendait elle a tiré
avec un fusil à pompe sur l'agent
pénitentiaire qui l'escortaient la
presse que disait ce docteur mouse en
fait on assiste à feu à la fin d'une
épidémie qui se traduit toujours la même
façon c'est-à-dire par un virus mutant
beaucoup plus contagieux mais très très
peu l'état est en train de se
transformer quasiment en grippe
d'ailleurs emmanuel macron l'a laissé
entendre lui même cher maires de france
vous avez le pouvoir de donner la parole
à des millions de français utilisent et
le et des moins ne vous laissez pas
voler cette élection les
intercommunalités les métropoles sont
tellement politisé et qu'il ya des
enjeux de pouvoir des enjeux de
subventions et des pressions terribles
sur les mères qui ne veut pas le prendre
de risque en donnant leur parrainage et
donc avant d'avoir des risques sur les
subventions pour leurs communes en garde
à vue jean alesi reconnaît les faits il
s'est bien rendu au cabinet d'architecte
de son beau-frère en pleine nuit
dimanche dernier avant de coincer un
énorme pétard dans l'encadrement de la
fenêtre de l'allumer et d' exploser la
vitre du bureau alerté par l'explosion
les voisins ont eu le temps de noter la
plaque d'immatriculation
alors qu'il filait dans la nuit en
voiture tous feux éteints le premier sms
de l'histoire vous savez on vous en a
parlé
il a été vendu hier cent sept mille
euros par la maison de ventes aguttes à
neuilly sur seine sans 7000 euros pour
sa mairie christmas joyeux noël